so first question what goal are you
hoping to accomplish through this show
Chrissy and Dave dying out number one
number two what do you want the viewers
to learn the
most and I'm gonna start with
Joel go down yeah my answer is like sort
of vaguely similar for both questions
like I think it's about accessibility
for me I think I especially came into
this show being one of those like Eat to
Live kinds of people I eat like terribly
lots of takeout lots of fast food and so
my palette was not as advanced as I
think these two were and I always looked
at restaurants like Providence for
instance as like fully you know way
outside of my comfort zone like that's
not going to be food for me it's
inaccessible and I think what I really
want people to understand is that
whether or not you're going to a
Michelin star restaurant or you're going
to like a a a secret you know hole in
the wall place that you might walk by
and not even notice that good food is is
available to everybody and you don't
have to have a super Advance palette to
enjoy it and understand it and um so
that's answer one what was question two
again can you repeat it one thing you
want the viewers to learn or take away
um I want the viewers to learn I think
especially after watching uh the pizza
biano episode with Chris biano is um
that food can be art I I did not think
about it in that way um so much before I
tasted his pizza and I never imagined I
would take a bite of pizza and say this
is Art until I ate there so that's me um
well I'll start I I would love people to
take away
well I think the most important thing to
take away from the show for me was the
passion that goes into
such a complicated and competitive
industry um I think the parts where I
got really emotional um were hearing the
stories
of the chefs themselves Chris biano had
such an incredible story um he was very
emotional and passionate about the food
that he serves and it's Pizza I mean uh
it's a simple food but when done
beautifully and done with passion and
with an artistic sensibility like Joel
said like it's really it's incredible to
see like the passion that's behind his
eyes like I teared up when he came to
the table and started speaking to us
about it um the industry is so hard to
survive La in New York like just imagine
how competitive it is we came out of
this show um wanting to
highlight um these businesses and these
restaurants um after a terrible terrible
pandemic um so I hope people are able to
take away that this is you know for some
of us it's just like a nice fun night
out but for the people that are owning
these restaurants that are chefs at
these restaurants this is their entire
life and um the passion is really there
and I thought it was so beautiful to see
um and sorry yeah what was the other
what's the goal so close I think you
kind of answered it though like the eie
yeah I think they're so similar that's
fine okay yeah well I'm nothing well you
got the hardest spot you got number
three yeah um well the I guess the
takeaway of the first bit probably not
the most original one but I do think
it's worth talking about is how amazing
these guys are as hosts right um we know
Joel's funny but I think the world gets
to see just how funny Chrissy is as well
and I think uh it's not easy hosting a
table full of diverse personalities and
successful people in the industry Etc
and I think you guys did a remarkable
job and huffing and puffing and being
like sitting with a baby belly on my
thighs oh my Lord like that was the
hardest part but it wasun you were
Trooper you know very very pregnant and
you crushed it right like we had such a
fun time and I think that hopefully that
comes across and um the the takeaway or
learn what was the second bit the learn
um that the conversations that we have
uh that I hope that people find that it
can be relatable right that they're not
so different than anybody else having a
normal conversation um and also I'd say
that I hope that people that are
watching somebody uh talking maybe they
know that P perspective of their life or
a story about them that changes how they
think about one of our dining Companions
and we were so lucky that so many
celebrities signed up to do this because
you know usually when you ask a
publicist they want to promote a project
or push something and this was less
about that and more about showing the
world a different side of them or or
hearing different things about them that
you didn't necessarily already know um
so yeah that part was really really cool
amazing
wonderful I'm so excited even more so
now after hearing y'all's responses to
my little
game exactly thank you thank you so much
I appreciate y'all bye thank you
bye